welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farin cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman once again
today
you know we've already talked a lot
about donald trump the documents
mar-a-lago the investigation and all
that and i don't want to continue
talking about that even though that is
dominating the news making it harder to
find any stories but there's one more
thing
i gotta talk about with it and that one
more thing
is trump's son donald trump jr
on monday donald trump jr
came down to my uh city of pensacola
florida to campaign of course for
republican candidate matt gates
which gates didn't really need it he was
going to win the primary easily but
junior comes down brings kimberly
guilfoyle with him they do an event and
it was during this event
that junior
started talking about the the
investigation into the documents and all
that stuff stored down there at
mar-a-lago and junior
not only defended his father but said
that if he had you know what i'm not
going to give it away i'm going to read
the quote
this is what donald trump jr said in
pensacola florida on monday
by the way for the record which okay you
don't have to put both of those
qualifiers in there
you would either say by the way or for
the record but you don't need to say by
the way for the record
just
a little grammar lesson there for
everybody
by the way for the record i'd say that
if donald trump actually still had the
nuclear codes
it'd probably be good
our enemies might actually be like okay
maybe let's not mess with them unlike
when they look at joe biden and they say
you know what we should attack now
see i was unaware
and maybe it's because of my sleepy
little town but i was unaware that
foreign leaders were actually out there
saying let's go attack america right now
have there been attacks like does it
happen while i'm sleeping and then
nobody tweets about it so i don't see it
the next day or
or is he just making stuff up because
he's a [ __ ]
i'm gonna go with the latter on that one
by the way um
[Music]
here's the other part of his incredibly
stupid statement
if donald trump still had nuclear codes
in those documents well guess what they
would no longer be valid i i can promise
you they've probably changed the codes
multiple times since donald trump left
office
but even assuming they hadn't right
let's indulge junior's little fantasy
here
assuming
they had not changed the nuclear codes
and donald trump did have them
he still couldn't issue a nuclear strike
and the rest of the world knows that
because he's not
the president of the united states does
junior think that anybody with those
nuclear codes is just able to order
a nuclear
strike i mean i guess if you did a good
enough you know biden impression
and you had the nuclear codes you you
might be able to do something like that
but um
just having the codes in and of themself
doesn't give you the authority
to launch nuclear weapons
so again
not 100 percent sure exactly what junior
is trying to tell us here
but i can tell you that everything he
says is completely false
like one we don't have world leaders
sitting around like oh trump's gone
great let's go fire missiles at america
because apparently what trump took the
entire military with him
is it is it just gone now like we didn't
just give them 800 billion dollars for
the next 12 months
did i make all that up
was that all just a fever dream that i
had
no the military is still there we still
have all the weapons that we had when
trump was there if not more at this
point obviously because we just picked
more up every year
so yeah the rest of the world still
knows that no matter who's in charge of
the white house
we can still do some pretty significant
damage to them if they were to come over
here and attack us
so
no matter which way you slice junior's
little weird fantasy there of trying to
defend his father's behavior
it makes no sense
and trust me i've been trying to make
sense of it for quite some time and dang
it
i simply cannot do it
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever spend
time planning it when what time of day
do i need to take each one i just get it
all with one scoop you can put it in a
smoothie you can drink it straight it
tastes great and then i'm just good for
the day it supports gut health and i'm
getting everything that i need and am
looking for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below